[Music]
adele is filling the love with boyfriend
rich paul as she steps out in style for
a wedding
absolutely over the weekend adele
watched nba star kevin love and sports
illustrated model kate bock say i do in
a great gatsby inspired wedding at the
new york public library naturally all
eyes were on the bride and groom
exchanging their vows at the elegant
affair it looks really amazing but we
can't take our eyes off the hello singer
giving us old hollywood glam adele stuns
in a black off the shoulder gown with
tousled tresses next to her man in a
classic tuxedo the couple posed with
lebron james and his wife savannah who
looked equally chic
obviously kevin and kate had an a-list
guest list so they set some ground rules
for their big day a source tells e.t
there was a very strict no phones rule
but once guests headed over to the
reception at the bryant park hotel we're
told everyone let loose and partied
including adele
[Music]
our source says adele and rich cut up on
the dance floor with some impressive
moves adding they were super cute and
attentive to one another we're told love
was in the air and they were definitely
feeling it
[Music]
the blushing bride recapped her dreamy
day on instagram kate recalls endless
smiles from her guest and says she and
kevin couldn't have felt more loved
along with adele and lebron some of
kevin's nba family was in attendance but
we're told lebron smiles stole the show
as he grinned watching speeches at the
reception it's a match made in heaven
and the spirits were flowing from the
reception to the after party held at
bryant park hotel
we're talking classy champagne towers
and guests toasting to the bride and
groom with lobos tequila the
over-the-top details didn't stop there
get this we're told kevin and kate
gifted everyone with a pair of air force
ones so they could be comfy on the dance
floor here's steve nash and his wife
lily sporting theirs before hitting the
dance floor with kicks like that we see
why adele and rich could dance the night
away i feel very lucky
[Music]
you